the Border in effect is open this is
exactly what the Democrats want and why
do they want it because they want more
Democrat voters they want more people to
come here and get on the Dole because
their policies will put people on the
Dole and they will in essence live like
modern slaves and by the way you don't
have to take my word for that because
that's what's been happening in
California in communist California they
bring in all of these people they
basically give them services and give
them phones and give them money they end
up ruining communities not even by their
own fault because there aren't enough
proper jobs also you should have to come
here legally and everything else and
even this is extraordinary guys because
this is a pretty rare one for me even
that soulless lizard person Gavin Newsom
even he now is realizing the results of
their policies and realizing that when
you bring in thousands of people and you
just give them stuff that a it's not
fair to the people who are legally here
or who are waiting online to get here
legally but it puts stress on the system
that the system cannot deal with Gavin
Newsom is realizing it I cannot believe
this I should be drinking
right now
in an interview with a national network
ABC News Governor Gavin Newsom said the
federal government should be doing more
to address the migrant crisis he said
the federal government keeps sending
planes and buses to California full of
migrants because of all the good work he
says the state is doing for the
Immigrant Community like providing
health care but he says the state is
simply overwhelmed he said with title 42
being lifted in just one week the state
will not be able to handle the influx he
said nine shelters along the border are
already at capacity the fact is what
we've got right now is not working and
is about to break in a post 42 World
unless we take some responsibility
ownership and I'm saying that as a
Democrat I'm not saying that to point
fingers I'm saying that as a father I'm
saying that as someone that feels
responsible for being part of the
solution and I'm trying to do my best
here okay I want to be clear about my
sympathy for Gavin Newsom I actually
have no sympathy for God and this is
exactly what he wants he's now using
this to try to hurt Biden right because
he wants to run for president for spot
and forced by now so that's that's all
obvious and I'm saying it as a
father-in-law it's like you're for all
this [ __ ] man you you're for all this uh
why are you giving illegal immigrants
health care if someone is here illegally
by definition they are breaking the law
you gotta go you gotta go I don't mean
to be a dick about it but you gotta go
you don't have to go home but you can't
stay here right that's the situation
that we are in with these people but
Gavin has done this to his State and I
would say good luck with all of that in
California because the implosion is on
the way and you guys voted for it and
you re-elected him and everything else